there are small action here we go four
guards it starts to get interesting
let's get scared Darth Maul will excel
in phase 2 and phase 3 every inside I
mean he's a great mobile attacker in to
serve as nitrate load quarters - oh you
have a perfectly absolutely I mean some
of these abilities you can see here he's
got metal in the back he's able to who
just rush in and out of combat and just
take eyes out the problem there's too
much specialist now so not everyone's
going to have any critic although it was
really fun in the original balance right
but I'm going to be excited it's hopping
to jump through French red key I mean I
know people we love this people love
people love to jump at oh yeah you've
got grey oh I I'm super excited to play
with her achieved
she's a quite a powerful character on
country uh you know she got out of that
one really don't run quickly but oh they
got many droid fallen by a Finnish Laroy
mistake nobo rey mysterio 19 Chang
absolutely so raise mind trick kids is
something that against all enemies will
be confused for a little bit your
controls were kind of no work against
you making you a little bit more
vulnerable to attack early and it's such
queue for close-quarters do you have any
like sort of strategy that you would add
absolutely I'm sure if you're the cones
you're hoping that og consoles is
getting torn up that's very troubled
it's like too soon manic every live
force awakens again you know like don't
do it Darth Maul is just destroying
absolutely everything